washington dc january 2022 a picture
postcard image but is it one which
belies a troubling and divided reality
it's a year since the event now known
simply as january 6th
a coup attempt an insurrection an effort
certainly by supporters of donald trump
to change the result of the election
[Applause]
as politicians hidden police were
overrun five people died and a nation
was shaken
about 12 months on team trump is as
active as ever and as defiant as ever
liz harrington is donald trump's
spokesperson and as president trump
likes to say the real insurrection was
the subversion of the american people's
will on november 3rd
that was
the
the theft
what january 6 was was the protest he
said we will fight we will fight like
hell and if you don't fight like hell
you're not going to have a country
anymore
that was incitement wasn't it no that's
nothing compared to what people on the
left say and you know he's speaking
metaphorically
[Applause]
but it has now emerged that as all this
was unfolding some of those closest to
mr trump including his own son were
urging the president to intervene it has
gone too far don jr said in a text
message
over the past year despite being banned
from social media donald trump has
remained in constant campaign mode and
he has continued to claim against all
facts but to audiences who believe him
that the election was stolen you are
saying that that former president trump
is still absolutely of the belief
that he won the election in 2020 yeah
absolutely and you look at it even
though even though 64 out of 65
challenges in courts around this nation
when there have been recounts and
recounts
they've checked very clearly
and those
have been proven to be very fair
elections or fair counts
no matter how many times you count the
same
stuffed ballot box
it's still going to be a stuffed ballot
box
yet audits too proved no wrong doing and
the dominant view among historians
academics those who would be dismissed
as the establishment is that democracy
itself in america is in a perilous state
republicans up and down the country have
arrived at a point where they look at
january 6 as a blueprint as a dress
rehearsal as a trial run for the next
presidential election and they are at
the state level trying to get themselves
in a position where at the next uh
presidential election they will be able
to execute that blueprint more
effectively as a way um to hold on to
power donald trump has not said whether
he will run again but a year since
january the sixth he has successfully
positioned himself as the commanding
force behind the republican party mark
stone sky news in washington d.c
[Music]